[Musique]
les enfants
bien les enfants aujourd'hui je vais
vous demander de dessiner nos deux îles
celle d'où l'on vient et celle où on vit
tout petit petit
[Musique]
et reconnaît l'école
c'est l'école primaire c'est simple
ce jour là
alors vous avez dessiné quand doudou
alors comment l'avez vous représentez
les maisons étaient très rapprochés et
les rues très étroites quoi d'autre il
n'y avait presque pas d'arbre moi il n'y
avait pas d'armes ok
c'était une île vraiment petit tout
petit c'est bien
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir phare est ici
tout est beaucoup plus grand
je vois quelque chose qu'il n'y avait
pas sur l'autre dessin
alain grand terrain de jeu et en plus il
ya plein de place on pourra construire
d'autres maisons ce sera pratique
ahmed l'instituteur de douves à farrou
la nouvelle il ne manque jamais une
occasion d'évoquer l'histoire de son
peuple cours de dessin ou de littérature
tout est bon pour rappeler aux élèves
d'où ils viennent
la plupart d'entre eux sont des enfants
de pêcheurs
l'ancienne icône toulouse où étaient
entourés d'eaux poissonneuses
depuis trois siècles les hommes se sont
nourris et enrichis grâce aux ressources
abondantes de l'endroit
comme doudou était l'une des plus
petites îles habitées de l'archipel
est l'une des plus denses près de 4000
personnes vivaient ici
sans récifs protecteur
lille a été balayée par le tsunami
26 décembre 2004
9h23 du matin un des habitants filmé
avec son téléphone portable la vague qui
fait basculer le destin de toute une île
de toute une vie
prévenu un quart d'heure plus tôt la
population était épargnée il n'y a que
deux morts
comme la plupart des hommes donnent ali
bey capitaine d'un des chalutiers de
lille était en mer et c'est par radio
qu'il prend connaissance de la
catastrophe
on est rentré aussi vite que possible
à notre arrivée ma femme a expliqué
qu'elle avait eu de l'eau jusque là
je me suis mis à pleurer
c'était le chaos
on était tous en état de choc ma femme
m'a dit vas vite chercher nos économies
dans le placard de la maison alors j'ai
couru mais il n'y avait plus rien tout
avait disparu
ça faisait trois mois à peine que
j'avais fini de construire notre maison
évacué le jour du tsunami la population
ne reviendra plus
les autorités jugent l'endroit trop
dangereux et quand doudou devient une
île déserte interdite
des familles entières sont dispersés
recueillis dans des camps de réfugiés
sur différentes îles où la cohabitation
est parfois difficile
l'exode va durer quatre ans
le peuple de qandil ou doux et
finalement relogées sur une nouvelle île
d'ouvéa phares ou dix fois plus grande
la communauté est reconstituée
ahmed l'instituteur est également
conseiller municipal
il a participé à toutes les décisions
qui ont précédé l'installation ici
avant le tsunami la situation à 32
doudou était devenue critique il était
devenu vraiment trop petit pour nous et
le gouvernement voulait de reloger
ailleurs
la plupart des gens ne voulaient pas
entendre parler d'un départ notamment
les pêcheurs eux ils voulaient rester
près des eaux poissonneuses de condom
moi j'étais un des seuls habilités pour
que nous partions et puis le tsunami
arrivait
avant de devenir terre d'asile douves à
farrou était unique désert
l'immense forêt de mangrove a laissé
place à 600 maisons deux écoles une
mosquée et un hôpital
c'est le plus gros projet de
reconstruction dans le pays après le
tsunami
il y a tout juste un an la communauté de
pêcheurs célébré en grande pompe son
arrivée ici en présence du président de
la république
m
le projet a vu le jour grâce à l'aide de
la croix rouge
kevin big man a été le responsable de
cet immense chantier permettant
d'accueillir le peuple de gauche de
l'aude où
j'ai travaillé aux maldives est un
véritable cauchemar logistique c'est
très compliqué tout doit être acheminée
par bateau les n'y a rien qui viennent
d'ici aucune ressource même l'eau il a
fallu la dessaliniser pour faire le
ciment on a construit une usine
spécialement pour ça tout absolument
tout vient de l'étranger les matériaux
viennent d'inde de malaisie d'indonésie
de chine d'australie et d'europe des
quatre coins du monde
après trois ans de travaux douves à
farrou l'île nouvelle est devenue une
cité modèle chaque famille a reçu sa
maison livrée clé en main
à candou l'aude où ahmed et sa famille
vivaient dans une seule pièce de trois
mètres sur trois ici l'espace paraît
parfois presque trop grand
toutes les maisons de ville ont été
construites sur le même plan ça a c'est
le salon où les enfants regardent la
télévision
ici c'est la salle à manger
voilà c'est le couloir qui mène aux
chambres
ça c'est la cuisine qui est grande et
kia tout le confort moderne
ici c'est un peu le bazar les enfants
viennent pour jouer dessinée il y ranger
leurs affaires
voilà leur chambre
ça c'est la salle de bain avec un puits
pour pomper l'eau
et là c'est notre chambre
si les jeunes se sont rapidement adaptés
à leur nouvelle île pour certains
anciens la mémoire l'histoire et les
souvenirs sont restés à quang do you do
à 65 ans harira s'efforce pourtant de
regarder devant elle pour accompagner
ses petits enfants
jamila cinq ans il n'a jamais connu
l'île natale de ses parents
mon petit fils a besoin d' espaces pour
grandir ici il ya de la terre il y à
tout l'espace nécessaire
ce n'était pas le cas là bas comme dans
le doubs ici nos enfants seront élevés
dans les meilleures conditions
de toute façon il n'ya pas d'avenir
raconte doudou on ne pourra jamais
reconstruire tout ce qui a été détruit
[Musique]
erreur
malgré le confort apparent et la
modernité des installations
aux yeux de ses habitants tout n'est pas
parfait du faron
en changeant deal en quittant kandolo
doux pour venir ici la communauté a
perdu plus que ces maisons et c'est bien
son mode de vie et ses traditions sont
aussi menacés
les relations familiales ont changé en
profondeur et certains peinent encore à
trouver leur place
à rire à ne se repose jamais
pourtant comme de nombreuses femmes de
la nouvelle il elle se sent bien souvent
aujourd'hui inutile
de l'aude où les pêcheurs revenait en
moyenne trois fois par jour les cales
pleines
et à chaque fois on les attendait pour
faire cuire le poisson
maintenant ils ne rentrent plus qu'une
fois par semaine elles ne rapportent
presque plus rien ici
ils vendent pratiquement tout a mal est
là bas je n'étais pas la seule personne
à cuisiner le poisson mais mes plats
avec tellement de succès que jean
préparait pour tout le monde
je n'ai plus ce bonheur là aujourd'hui
le poisson constitue la seule ressource
du peuple de comptes de l'aude où les
pêcheurs sont connus pour être parmi les
plus riches des maldives ils le doivent
aux tons qui abondent à quelques
encablures de ligne
la plupart d'entre eux
connaissent la zone par coeur depuis
leur plus jeune âge
déplacer à douma faroun ne tarde pas à
s'apercevoir que leur nouvelle il ne
dispose pas des mêmes ressources que
can't do you do
pour eux la décision s'impose il faut
retourner pêcher vers l'ancienne ille à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de là c'est
la survie de la communauté qui est en
jeu
au large de candos l'aude où les bons
jours chaque membre d'équipage peut
espérer retirer jusqu'à 200 kg de
poissons
pour le connaître
ici il y a beaucoup de thon jaune c'est
une zone où on en trouve en quantité
toute l'année
c'est pour ça qu'on pêche dans le coin
il suffit de suivre les dauphins pour
repérer des normes banc de thons
chaque semaine on pêche en moyenne entre
15 et 17 heures
sur la nouvelle il le vendredi est
désormais le seul jour de la semaine où
toutes les familles sont réunis pour
ahmed l'instituteur c'est souvent
l'occasion d'aller à la plage un
changement de taille par rapport aux
activités qu'ils pouvaient avoir avant
il ya beaucoup de choses que quand de
loup n'avait pas par exemple il n'y
avait pas de plage à la place il y avait
une grande digue qui en certaines îles
on n'avait jamais vu de belles plages de
sable blanc comme celle là quand on
vivait là-bas
pourtant nous en avions besoin comme que
les habitants de ce pays
vous imaginez ce que c'est de vivre ici
sans même pouvoir profiter du bord de
mer
vous savez aux maldives quand toulouse
où est la seule île où il n'y avait pas
de plage
la prière du vendredi est la plus suivie
elle rassemble tous les hommes de l'île
ahmed et donne à libé le pêcheur s'y
rendent régulièrement ensemble
[Musique]
mais depuis leur arrivée à douves à
farrou leur vie sont très différentes
l'instituteur est présent toute la
semaine quand le capitaine est ici que
ce jour là
bella
là
comme la plupart des pêcheurs de sa
communauté
donald ebay fait vivre une famille
nombreuse qui doit désormais composer au
quotidien sans lui
il passe l'essentiel de son temps en mer
et suit la vie des siens à distance
aujourd'hui je suis absent six jours sur
sept bien évidemment je suis triste de
voir si peu ma famille mes enfants me
manque et je pense souvent à eux quand
je suis sur mon bateau avant je rentrais
chez moi tous les soirs alors oui c'est
vrai c'est dommage que l'on est à vivre
de cette façon désormais
le vendredi 12 à farrou s'anime aussi de
multiples activités sportives pour les
hommes et pour les femmes
la communauté peut enfin voir les choses
en grand
un stade a été construit et l'équipe de
football au sein de laquelle ahmed
l'instituteur et milieu de terrain peut
ainsi défendre ses chances dans le
championnat des maldives devant ses
supporters
[Musique]
à l'époque on vivait à contre toulouse
où on devait se déplacer dans les îles
voisines pour jouer
vous prenez le bateau et on jouait tous
nos matches à l'extérieur
c'était pas facile à organiser
maintenant tout est beaucoup plus simple
je suis heureux de voir mes copains vont
pouvoir assister aux matchs avec eux et
j'ai encore quelques heures pour en
profiter
à la tombée du jour les premiers bateaux
repartent déjà
donald ebay les autres pêcheurs de l'île
les suivrons de près
sur leur nouvelle il les familles ont
gagné au change mais sans poisson les
pêcheurs n'ont d'autre solution que de
retourner sur les lieux qui depuis des
siècles les font vivre dans les eaux de
kando loudoux où leur présence ne devait
rien au hasard
la technique de pêche est immuable
l'arrosage et les a peints attire le
thon jaune en surface à bord les hommes
peuvent commencer leur ballet lancé sans
relâche leurs cannes équipé d'un simple
hameçon
on a bien essayé de pêcher à tout-va
farine mais il n'y a pas de poisson là
bas s'il y avait de quoi pêché près de
notre nouvelle il croyez-moi on
resterait sur place mais ce n'est pas le
cas pour le poisson ici on n'a rien
trouvé
quand les caleçons plein c'est à candos
loudoux que les pêcheurs des charges et
conditionne les poissons du jour pour
donald ib et ses marins c'est l'éternel
retour
d'abord purement et simplement
interdites d'accès quant au loup nous
est devenu un lieu de travail
devant l'obstination des pêcheurs à
revenir ici le gouvernement a finalement
cédé mais il interdit encore de passer
la nuit sur l'île de l'habiter à nouveau
[Musique]
donald ib profite de ses passages pour
faire régulièrement quelques pas dans la
cité déserte mais il préfère ne pas se
rendre sur les lieux de son ancienne
maison son île natale n'est plus qu'un
marché aux poissons
quant au loudes où il restait une des
places fortes de la pêche aux maldives
sur le port la nuit l'activité bat son
plein comme avant
le poisson était fils est cuit salée et
séchée sur place
[Musique]
le marché s'est organisée
vendeurs et acheteurs décide du prix de
la destination du thon jaune
selon sa qualité il sera acheminé vers
malé la capitale ou exportés vers le sri
lanka l'inde où même l'europe
quand la journée de travail est terminé
les hommes regagnent leur embarcation ce
soir encore ils dormiront en mer
la nouvelle il devait préfigurer un
modèle de déplacement réussite
population les autorités en avaient fait
un test grandeur nature pour préparer
l'avenir incertain devant la montée des
eaux un test dans un archipel où chacun
sera tôt ou tard amené à migrer à
douvres à faro au moins pour quelques
temps les familles seront mieux protégés
mais les autorités avaient oublié
l'essentiel pour des pêcheurs pas de vie
sans poisson est temps que le ton sera
abondant à gandalou d'où les pêcheurs
continuerons à donner vie à leurs
anciennes il
[Musique]